music to our ears
when Stefani and Blake Shelton are going
to take the stage together Carson Daly
announced the exciting news on the voice
Tuesday night and Blake confirmed on
Twitter writing quote so I'm performing
next week on The Voice I'm performing
with Gwen Stefani we're performing a
song off my album you wrote together
the duo wrote the song go ahead and
break my heart together last fall and
Gwen revealed on Twitter just last month
that it would appear as the 9th track on
Shelton's upcoming album if I'm honest
et spoke with Shelton recently where
he's Gus over the song we actually wrote
the song together she and I which is
very personal for us this song I
hesitate to brag on it too much but I
really think that it's as good of a song
as I've ever written in my life people
are gonna hear it and they'll make
everything it's a it's a full-blown duet
this is this is a 50/50 performance and
we can't wait make sure to tune into the
voice next Monday to see the couple
perform we know we will